[Musique]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous
pouvez vous asseoir et le coq chante et
danse et de musique asseyez vous
asseyez vous
monsieur comment il s'appelle i quoi
[Musique]
asseyez-vous
ce qui est honteux c'est ce que vous
êtes en train de faire monsieur là ça
vous n'avez pas à vous lever et à hurler
dans l'assemblée le berner privé de
micro s'est mise en colère pour faire
entendre son avis tu viens ici 50
députés qui ne servent à rien c'est
honteux vous poussez un vieux savon
tenir tête s'il vous plaît calmez vous
dire à salbris y ait immédiatement
retiré ce gilet
parfait monsieur la salle ce rappel au
règlement sera évidemment inscrits au
procès verbal et vous en subirez les
conséquences
retirer s'il vous plaît ce gilet
sur la salle
depuis 16 jours le député udf des
pyrénées atlantiques ne quitte plus ce
canapé de la salle des quatre colonnes
une grève de la faim ses larmes ultime
qui l'a choisi pour protester contre la
délocalisation d'une usine japonaise
implanté dans sa circonscription 150
emplois sont menacés son état devient
critique au bout de 37 jours il a déjà
perdu 21 kilos
suite mais il refuse de parler de
victoire mais au bout de trente neuf
jours de grève de la faim jean lassalle
a obtenu ce qu'il voulait il vient de
signer un accord avec total est porté à
la vérité je je je croyais pas jean
lassalle a remisé son béret ses
chaussures de marche lui qui était
partie il ya huit mois au chevet des
français revient les jambes lourdes des
6000 kilomètres parcourus mais surtout
l'esprit marquée par la colère du pays
une fois votre politique jean lassalle
c'est celle des coups d'éclat
non je n'aimais pas ça mais des
circonstances ont voulu que je n'ai
jamais pu m'exprimer
normalement
c'est un peu ma faute
j'ai suivis très longtemps françois
bayrou
qui est dedans j'ai beaucoup appris qui
a peut-être un peu a pris deux mois mais
il était premier de cordée
ce n'est que lorsque j'ai compris que
nous disions même chose même nous ne
faisions absolument plus du tout la même
chose qu'eux ils n'avaient pas compris
que nous étions en train de perdre une
nouvelle bataille décisive celle
que gagnaient la financiarisation croisé
à outrance dans le monde entier que je
les ai quittés et si vous être ça qui a
fait que j'étais un peu en décalage
sinon je n'ai pas pu supporter un
certain nombre de décisions très
symbolique de ces vingt dernières années
et chaque fois je me suis levé je me
suis levé lorsque
refermez l'empêcher de maintenir une
gendarmerie et d'ouvrir une centres de
secours alors que je venais de finir le
tunnel le plus long d'europe nous sommes
par 8,6 à les deux tunnels des alpes les
brûler l'année auparavant mme le mot
sony et le mont-blanc 400 marches je ne
voulais pas la honte sur le fond de mes
fils j'ai
fait la grève de la faim omar ou ou
totale qu'il n'avait rien fait dans
notre département
m'arracher une gym je vais chercher au
japon et nous en perdions 400 mis la
france à la même époque je l'avais dit à
jacques chirac à plusieurs reprises je
le dis on se relèvera pas j'ai marché
quand j'ai compris que nous étions en
train de nom
d'éclater cette ce vieux peuple
souverain s'était déclaré sûr rey était
en train de devenir un as mains d'hommes
et de femmes courant dans tous les sens
ce serait après le passage d'un tsunami
et j'ai mis ce gilet jaune lorsque j'ai
compris que tous les députés devraient
être sur les ronds-points parce que ce
vieux peuple avait trouvé le moyen de
faire de dire plus en six mois sur nos
conditions de vie que nous l'avions fait
durant 30 ans
[Musique]